mohammad javad tarifs s'exprimer pour la
première fois devant les députés depuis
qu'a commencé fin mai la nouvelle
mandature du parlement iranien
face aux élus en majorité conservateurs
le chef de la diplomatie de la
république islamique a dévoilé un projet
de partenariat stratégique en cours de
négociation avec la chine
un discours qui survient après une
polémique sur les réseaux sociaux
annonçant des discussions en cours avec
un pays étranger avec assurance et
conviction nous sommes en train de
négocier avec la chine un accord
stratégique pour 25 ans je dois dire à
la nation iranienne qu'il n'y a rien de
secret dans le contrat avec la chine
quand monsieur xvi a rencontré le guide
suprême et parler des relations
stratégiques entre l'iran et la chine
ainsi que de l'accord pour 25 ans nous
l'avons tout de suite annoncé mohammad
javad zarif fait référence à la visite
du président chinois à téhéran janvier
2016 la chine et l'iran s'était alors
engagé à négocier afin de conclure un
accord de coopération accord prévoyant
des investissements réciproques dans
différents domaines tels que les
transports les ports l'énergie
l'industrie et les services
le gouvernement et le peuple iranien
cherche comme ils l'ont toujours fait à
élargir leurs relations avec des pays
indépendants et fiables tels que la
chine premier partenaire commercial de
téhéran
la chine était aussi l'un des principaux
acheteurs de pétrole iranien avant le
rétablissement des sanctions américaines
contre le secteur énergétique de la
république islamique sous l'impulsion de
donald trump
les etats unis se sont en effet retiré
de l'accord international sur le
nucléaire iranien conclu en 2015 avec
les puissances partenaires dans un
contexte de plus en plus tendues avec
washington l'iran déjà proche de moscou
a donc souhaité renforcer ses liens avec
la chine
fin juin la russie et la chine se sont
opposés à une résolution américaine
prévoyant une extension sans limite de
l'embargo sur les armes imposé à la
république islamique